E aí
[Música]
e
com quem você fala quando você não tem
mais ninguém com quem conversar a
pesquisa O Silêncio dos homens de 2019
mostrou que seis em cada dez homens
afirma sofrer de algum tipo de distúrbio
emocional mesmo assim setenta por cento
deles não tem coragem de falar com seus
melhores amigos são seus maiores medos
a cor você é homem você é ensinada que
você não pode demonstrar o menor sinal
de fraqueza ou insegurança mas com quem
você vai tirar uma dúvida quando você
quer saber algo sobre a vida o universo
e tudo mais
e há quase dez anos meu trabalho e se
falar com homens falar com eles sobre
aquilo que eles não tem coragem de falar
com mais ninguém começou em 2011 já
acabado de me formar na faculdade e eu
tava cansado daquele sentimento de ser
um boss adolescente eu quero me sentir o
que eu achava na época seu homem de
verdade eu sou buscar ajuda para isso as
revistas que eram publicadas isso que eu
vi que nenhuma delas falava exatamente
para mim ou elas eram cem porcento
voltadas para mim os ricos e preencher
de vida o qual eu jamais poderia pagar
agora estavam mais preocupadas em
publicar as fotos eróticas do que
qualquer outro tipo de coisa
e na internet deste alguns blogs mas a
grande maioria deles apenas publicar vá
conteúdos e piadas machistas e
homofóbicas
vai assim que eu resolvi criar um espaço
para falar com caras nem eu e assim
nasceu o manual do homem moderno a ideia
desde o começo para essa que é um espaço
para conversar de homem para homem uma
conversa franca e sincera sem julgamento
sem preconceitos em machismo sem cair
naquele lugar comum dizer o que o homem
deve ou não fazer para ser mais homem
a nossa ideia era falar sobre
sentimentos medo moda relacionamento
todos aqueles assuntos que nem sempre
são bem-vindos em rodas de conversas de
homens parece a grande maioria dos
homens dificilmente vai ter uma conversa
profunda cuja resposta valendi a dia
homem isso é frescura para com isso
a j.k. alguns dos meus vídeos já
passaram de milhões de visualizações
entre eles vou deixar a barba crescer
como cuidar melhor do seu dinheiro e
claro como fazer sexo pela primeira vez
e todos eles a metodologia muito simples
a gente é didático direto ao ponto
complicado descontraído se dá para levar
um assunto com leveza gente leva para
curar se sinta à vontade de ter essas
conversas com a gente o exemplo de
abordagem do nosso conteúdo foi uma
série de vídeos que eu fiz sobre
términos de relacionamento é muito comum
quando você é homem e termina um
relacionamento você ouve coisas como as
é para pegar umas meninas albere que
você esquece o o tempo cura tudo Relaxa
conselhos que quase sempre são
bem-intencionados mas eles não ajudam
muito a você lidar com aquele sentimento
de rejeição aquela angústia aquela dor
daquela perda
o dessa série de vídeos eu quis fazer
diferente eu falei sobre a importância
de você chorar de você pegar um tempo
para cuidar de você mesmo mais de
Queremos mais o que você quer mostrar
para o mundo como você tá saindo por
cima tá pegando todo mundo tá vivendo a
vida Incrivelmente não cuidado que tá
acontecendo aqui dentro dos seus
sentimentos
algo que ninguém me ensinou quando era
mais novo
E conforme o projeto cresceu e o
endereço aí eu queria um manual do homem
moderno colete há 25 anos e hoje eu
tenho 34
o que começou com o papa de brother para
brother Começou a tomar um tão diferente
quando a gente se ligou que a gente tava
falando com a galera que era mais nova
até mesmo do que eu quando eu criei o
projeto
hoje a gente tá falando com uma nova
geração que tá começando a viver tudo
aquilo que a gente já viveu cheio de
dúvidas medos e anseios eles caem no
nosso conteúdo para responder às
perguntas que eles não têm para quem
perguntar ou até mesmo diz não sabe se
podem perguntar pra alguém por exemplo
disso fimose Eu tenho dois vídeos sobre
fimose aqui juntos eles somam 2 milhões
de visualizações
depois da publicação desses a gente
recebeu uma série de relatos de meninos
e homens adultos que fizeram operação
que se identificaram com quadro após ver
esse conteúdo algo que um pai de verdade
até que tá na primeira infância mas não
detector algo que um jovem devia ter os
instrumentos de uma aula de educação
sexual para descobrir essa função do
próprio corpo mas não te vi é necessário
Um Estranho na internet para lidar com
uma questão torrent
E aí você vai me perguntar como é que
alguém se sente à vontade de abrir uma
coisa tão pessoal na sua vida com alguém
que eles nem conhece
quando você é homem por muitas vezes
você se sente mais à vontade de falar
com alguém você não faz a menor ideia de
quem seja do que se abrir com uma pessoa
do seu círculo mais pessoal e virar
motivo de piada e ser humilhado por isso
é muito disso começa em casa o próprio
pai
e ele não quer conversa mais profunda de
sexo que eu tive com meu pai por uma vez
que eu tava no meu quarto jogando
PlayStation ele entrou jogou uma
camiseta no meu colo e me se você
engravidar alguém eu te mato
e eu tinha 15 anos e tirando o uma outra
aula de educação sexual na escola isso
foi tudo que falar em sexo comigo o
resto tive que aprender sozinho na vida
Eu também não posso contar muito meu pai
já que ele cresceu sem pai como é que
você entende esse tipo de dilema de um
jovem se você não tem uma referência
para isso e infelizmente não é um caso
isolado
segundo dados de pé hoje no Brasil 12
milhões de mães criam seus filhos sem
ajuda do pai biológico se mudado do
registro civil Seis por cento das
crianças que são registradas todos os
anos não tem o nome do pai na certidão
e o Brasil é um país em paz da Seleção
Brasileira entrou para disputar a Copa
do Mundo de 2018 seis dos onze jogadores
cresceram longe do pai Paulinho Casimiro
Miranda Thiago Silva Marcelo Gabriel
Jesus não tiver um referencial masculino
dentro de casa uma realidade muito comum
no País do Futebol
e quando você é homem você ensinar ali
que você tem que estar sempre no
controle não pode ter medos inseguranças
dúvidas isso é muito pior e começa na
adolescência
você chega na adolescência Rio de medos
você passa uma série de mudanças em seu
corpo muda sua cabeça muda suas vontades
seus desejos tudo muda de uma vez só e
às vezes mesmo tendo o pai por perto
como eu tive você me encontra alguém uma
rede de apoio para te ajudar com
questões estão últimas para uma geração
que nasce e cresce com celular na mão a
internet é o lugar onde eles vão buscar
essas respostas e aí começam os
problemas
um deles noventa porcento dos meninos
isso é de sessenta por cento das meninas
vão assistir algum filme pornográfico
antes dos 18 anos e que não recebe
Educação de qualidade o que tá na tela
você tá na referência e assim o pano se
torna educação sexual e é basicamente a
mesma coisa que você me dizer que você
sabe dirigir só porque você assistiu a
todos os filmes do Velozes e Furiosos
uma das dúvidas que eu mais recebo É
sobre o próprio pênis será que ele é
pequeno demais Será que eu vou saber o
que fazer com ele será que meu parceiro
minha parceira vai gostar
Pedro calma 15 centímetros tá ótimo Vai
com calma presta atenção no que seu
parceiro nos aparecerá tá achando não
esquece de mandar uma mensagem no dia
seguinte
e olha apesar de ser super bem
intencionado o resultado de anos de
profissão Eu Ainda Sou Um Estranho na
internet e muitos jovens ainda preferem
falar com estranhos na internet do que
com o próprio pai ou com própria mãe
isso é uma certeza eu posso dar para
você é que nem todos estranhos na
internet são tão bem intencionadas
quando eu sou e nos últimos anos a gente
tem que crescer cada vez mais movimentos
feministas negacionistas episódios todos
eles com a base muito forte em jovem em
grupos de redes sociais e são
frequentados por eles eles se aproveitam
da necessidade de pertencimento dessa
vulnerabilidade para vender essas idéias
tortas
a gente quer que nossos jovens cresçam
como homem saudáveis e Parem de
reproduzir comportamento de risco e
machismo mais do que está por perto a
gente tem que dar presente
esquecem-se de áudio que a escola vai
educar os nossos filhos e entender o que
está por trás de cada medo de cada um
seio de cada insegurança
quantos pais não estão delegando a
educação de seus filhos para tablets e
celulares para mecanismos de busca a
gente precisa aprender Abrir linhas de
diálogos com homens desde cedo da
instrumentos para eles lidarem com suas
inseguranças
mostrar para eles que mais do que o
violência dá para lidar com boa parte
dos problemas da vida com inteligência a
maioria dos conteúdos público hoje
me responde conversas que eu queria ter
tido anos atrás mas não tinha ninguém
para falar comigo e quando tinha a
resposta nunca iria muito além de virar
homem
se a gente não começar abrir essa linha
de diálogo com os nossos homens a gente
vai estar entregando eles de bandeja
para estranhos na internet e pode
acreditar que nem sempre o resultado da
busca vai ser positivo
a minha pergunta agora é será que você
alguém com que um homem pode conversar
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]